[Applause]
did you know that prince
charles is the main era of cal dracula
i know i agree that sounds insane i bet
you
one million dollars bring that up jamie
prince charles count dracula thank you
prince charles is the heir of count
dracula
he moved in five years ago to count
dracula's castle and he lives with a
group
of homeless of homeless children no he
does not
i swear to god prince charles prince
harry's dad
prince charles the heir of the throne of
the dragon
okay there's a transylvanian according
to this google search
from the express dot co dot uk prince
charles his distant kinship to vlad
tepes the 15th century wacholin ruler
whom the irish novelist based his
dracula prince charles like the one that
we all know prince charles yeah he's
related to count chocula
or dracula but it's way worse than that
and then he lives in dracula castle with
children
according to express.com i swear to god
he lives with you that's also on his
breath
according to this british tabloid he had
five punches right in the nose
he lives it says with the orphans
in the castle prince charles
pull up prince charles dracula castle
that's how you do a google search
yeah you just cut your [ __ ] this guy's
good good at googling it prince
charles dracula castle look it up jamie
okay
uh everyone's gonna do this you're gonna
find out my line
and i remember like 10 years ago finally
he's like he's like i live in the cat
little boys like i live in a castle with
them
it's like dracula castle on a mountain
like you saw in the movies
is that why they say andrew's the
pedophile to distract from charles
prince
andrew
you are crazy
now you really got me onto some [ __ ] the
worst things that you do
the more interconnected you are with
these inner dimensional
beings you have to commit these crimes
against humanity to prove your credit
why do you have to prove your credit in
that way because they're damn demons so
how do you
higher order stuff doesn't involve
itself like do you think of god like
god's way up there but there's always
other stuff god created
god doesn't get involved with your
personal decisions only demons do
so god's not going to manipulate free
will
is this the the whole like star wars
dilemma between the good and the
what is it the light power the dark
power what is the dark side dark side
the force
i mean you see this kind of metaphor
happen right
did you find it which one the little
boys prince charles
no no no no prince charles lives at cal
dracula
according to travelmakertours.com
there's an article they have from 2017
that says why prince charles considers
transylvania his second home
it doesn't necessarily say anything
about children but i like this voice
but the point stands but perhaps he
considers transylvania his second home
i don't know prince charles
lives at dracula's castle no no i'm not
joking
no no don't listen i'm not joking think
of how weird that is
he he lives in contract
okay so you pulled back by 30 35 percent
you would really change the phone nah
but you got to come through and just
slap
bars bro like saying something like that
like he speaks in youtube titles yeah
nuance
like all the things that you say are
youtube click bait
nuance isn't interesting [ __ ] nuance bro
prince charles
lives even if he vacations [ __ ]
vacations oh he lives here
he lives at the euro
and he lives there with young boys
and he feasts on them no no it says he
says oh
prince charles hugs local boys and live
with him at the castle
dracula you're really like newspaper
arnold's
like little kids are hugging he's like
ah and it's real man
what do you think about this whole
meghan markle thing that's the video
have you watched about the the oprah
thing maybe that's that was i
wanted to ask him but like well the
whole cue thing not the cue thing
oprah and oprah interviewed meghan
markle and harry
do you know they are gary you no harry
prince harry prince
prince yeah the fake prince the redhead
prince ginger prince and his black wife
who left the family and they're alleging
some crazy [ __ ]
yeah they're like saying they kill
princess diana what i feel like you're
about to throw
up and that would be so funny
i would love it what's funny is my wife
and kids are waiting out there
i'll go for hours and hours look at this
look at this hold on
wait go so tell me what the deal is with
leisure buddy no tell us what the deal
is with meghan markle man
megan merkel
[Music]
[Laughter]
german chancellor meghan markle
are you talking about like prince
harry's wife yes
yes princess they're these horrible
people
that like glommed on it's well known
that but then they left they left the
world
yeah it's okay let's get serious
what happened is
[Laughter]
hey oh it's my dick like a gold gold
dick and women will be worshiping that
yeah that's a gold winnie
yep
[Laughter]
it's well known yeah according to the
lord
that
prince charles's wife didn't like him
and she had a kid with this
british colonel or something that is the
redhead
demon i love what he says is well known
and says some [ __ ] no one has ever heard
anyway look up not a big lie about this
she had sex with with a man that wasn't
prince charles
and they created the redhead demons
okay and now since they've created
created that person
now since they got him they said he
is bad but the truth is merkel
and him are now hollywood [ __ ] and
they run around [ __ ] all day
so that that's what matters is there oh
no princess diana cheated with the
captain of the guards redhead carrot
head
another wrong carrot and they had the
carrot carrot baby
they had the carrot baby
and once they had the carrot baby
you